hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to
give you some quick
tips on how to assess for veins before
you start a peripheral ivy
before performing any nursing skills you
want to make sure that you're following
your hospital's protocols
to ensure you're following the latest
guidelines
now i'm going to assess the patient's
arm in order to find a vein that is good
enough for an iv that i want to insert
in them
so before i do that i want to perform
hand hygiene again before i even touch
the patient and then i want to
grab the tourniquet that i had in my iv
start kit
now applying the tourniquet what it's
going to do is it's going to
put pressure on these veins and cause
them to pop out more
you don't always have to use a
tourniquet if your patient has
just really bulging veins you may not
want to use one because too much
pressure could blow them
this patient has great veins so i'm
going to use a tourniquet very
lightly just to give us a little bit of
increased pressure
so i'm going to place the tourniquet on
the arm
and what you do is you put it around and
it's sort of like tying a shoe so you're
going to take it out
and then you're going to cross it and
then you're going to make this bunny ear
so we're going to go here and just make
a bunny ear
and that is just going to apply pressure
on our veins and the reason we tie it
like this is because we want to be able
to
quickly release it so just do this
and it quickly releases it now whenever
you're looking for veins you want to go
in an
area where you know you're going to find
some veins and in most patients they're
usually going to be in the same spot
so whenever you're first starting out
you need to know what a vein feels like
veins are very springy feeling and they
do not pulsate if it pulsates it's an
artery
and um the best way is you know to feel
on yourself
feel those veins and get an idea of what
it feels like and look for them and just
know where they normally hang out in the
body
so the antecubital area is a great place
to look
there's usually large veins there they
tend to be a little bit deeper
in this area of the area than compared
to let's say the hand
but he has one right here and right here
those are usually
great places especially for drawing
blood and then we can also
look at the forearm and some patients
depending on their disease process
and what they have going on you may find
some
in the forearm if they have a lot of
adipose tissue you may not see them as
well but this patient you can see them
very nicely and then whenever you turn
over the arm you can see them
there as well and then there is the hand
and the hand usually has great veins in
it that are
superficial easy to get to but one thing
you want to remember about the hand is
that it is a little bit more sensitive
to the patient
and these veins because they are so
superficial
they do like to roll so it's very
important that you stabilize
the iv site before you stick it because
whenever i'm talking about rolling what
i'm meaning is that
whenever something goes to penetrate the
skin it can easily cause that vein just
to go to the side like this and just
watch my finger touch this thing see
how that goes to the side like that if
we put a needle
there with our iv we would hit it and
then the pain would just go to the side
and you would just be in the tissue so
it's very important you have the patient
just
you know tighten their hand a little bit
and then you go and stabilize it by
pulling the skin like that before you
stick
so when you have found a vein to stick
you want to make sure that you ask
yourself okay is this vein good enough
number one
is this vein going to hold this iv gauge
that i've selected like
if you're going to be putting in a large
gauge let's say an 18 gauge
you don't want to go in a really small
vein because
it's probably going to blow so you want
to make sure you pick a good enough size
vein
also look at how that vein is designed
is it
nice and straight try to find veins that
are straight because
if they curve around they may be hard to
thread that plastic cannula into
so try to select a nice straight one and
pick a site that is feasible to your
patient now i know
a lot of times whenever you're taking
care of patients in the hospital
you're just going to use whatever vein
you can get because that patient is so
sick and they don't have a lot to choose
from
but if you do have some things to choose
from try to choose something that's good
for your patient
like the ac if your patient's going to
have a lot of fluids running
you don't want to probably go here
because naturally your patient wants to
bend their arm they're going to be
eating they're going to be moving around
the bed
and if they have fluids running when you
bend the arm
your pump's going to be because it's
occluded you're going to have to go fix
it or it's going to drive your patient
crazy
so also that site can be very painful
because they're naturally bending their
arm as well so just keep those things in
mind so i know what vein i'm going to
use
on this patient to start an iv so i'm
going to go ahead and just remove this
tourniquet
temporarily and set everything up okay
so that wraps up this video and if you
would like to watch
more videos on nursing skills you can
access the link in the youtube
description below